the thing that puts us in such an
existential situation individually and
culturally is this puzzlement over our
origins
we are not strictly speaking religious
in the 19th century way so that we
cannot really I think accept that you
know God sculpted us from clay and set
us down here on a world he created and
yet if you were to look for the
thumbprint of God on this planet you
would certainly have to focus in on the
human beings and their activities as a
special case of natural phenomena
perhaps so special a case that it had to
be accorded a separate ontological
status we are different and why and for
what I think that probably we are the
agent of change that Gaia has unleashed
upon herself but the planet itself is
aware of the finiteness of planetary
existence and it's sort of like the
story of the ant and the grasshopper you
can have a planetary consciousness which
says well I look forward to three to
five billion years of sentient existence
and then I'm willing to be extinguished
with the death of my star or you can
have a planet with an ant like mentality
that says you know I can sense winter
coming three to five billion years down
the line and I'm going to organize some
wild strategy to break through the
tyranny of the energy cycle of one star
and I am going to organize biological
existence so that energy can be brought
greater and greater amounts of energy
can be brought under control so that
eventually a kind of liberation can
occur where life can burst out of the
planetary cradle
and disburse itself through the universe
and there are apparently several
strategies for this one is evolved
intelligence and build starships another
is you know become a mushroom and
produce three to five million spores per
minute during sporulation that are
particles small enough to percolate by
Brownian movement away from the
atmosphere of a given planet and by
sheer numbers and the slow gradient of
drift by light pressure and that sort of
thing emanate through the universe and
establish yourself in any planetary
regime that is suitable
the obvious next great revelation in
biology and it's strange that we can
state it because once it's stated by
Carl Sagan it will be headlines
everywhere but it's obvious that space
is no barrier to life it's a it's a it's
a barrier in the same way that the
Pacific Ocean it was a barrier to life's
colonization of the Hawaiian Islands but
that's all it's just a tight filter that
spores and starships and shamans
probably get through to other closed
topologies in orbit around other stars
you know there must be a dimension
somewhere where all surfaces in the
universe are contiguous and if you could
move into that dimension you could just
walk to Zeta Reticuli so the means by
which life will penetrate these larger
dimensions that free it from its
dependency on the energy cycles of the
material universe are not by any means
clear I mean it may
be that it's about organizing the mind
and building an inner vehicle that moves
off into the imagination the imagination
may be in fact a three-dimensional slice
of a higher dimensional universe that is
holding all of this in being and causing
it to happen the imagination gets hard
to account for it in evolutionary terms
if it is not - somehow mapping a field
of data that is important for
development
[Music]
[Music]
you